imagine if it's not too much of a
stretch of the imagination a world in
which carbon is building up in the
atmosphere but in this world nobody
wants to own up to emitting that carbon
governments swear they don't emit
anything into the
atmosphere so they came to me the most
available atmospheric detective in town
how do you trace an invisible gas a gas
that's a tiny fraction of the atmosphere
a witness that you can't r up or pour a
tall drink or threaten to throw off a
building not that I'd ever actually do
that I tried everything I was all out of
ideas okay I tried basically nothing but
I was all out of ideas but then she
walked in the European Space Agency
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video to learn more about science maths
and computer science head to
brilliant.org Simon Clark we constantly
hear about the carbon emissions of
different countries and whether those
emissions are going going up or down but
how do we know these numbers it may
surprise you to learn that we can detect
how much of an invisible gas countries
emit from space the European space
agency and other space agencies like
NASA and jaxa have constellations of
satellites monitoring the planet in a
previous video I spoke with Dr clemont
Abel of issa's climate office about how
those satellites have their biases
removed and what exactly that means and
during that video we were talking about
carbon emissions and Dr Alber gel
totally blindsided me so to be clear
you're not measuring it's not like
you're seeing clouds of CO2 leaving a
country you're doing a almost like a
hind cast we can scan we can scan in
time and have information on a
concentration of greenhouse gas at a
specific time uh and space and we need
to put that in an atmospheric uh model
and inverse this model to backtrack the
concentration from its uh emission
clearly I was not aware of this
technique before so let's unpack what
cemon just said when you think of
satellites monitoring the Earth you
probably think of measurements of things
like temperature humidity winds and so
on we take those measurements partly so
we can input them into models of the
atmosphere as an initial State and then
let the Dynamics of that atmospheric
model move air and heat and moisture
around allowing us to guess what the
atmosphere will look like in the near
future and predict the weather but as we
learned in that previous video there are
dozens of essential climate VAR Ables
that are monitored by these agencies and
one of those ecvs is carbon dioxide
concentration for reasons that I hope
are obvious now famously CO2 has been
continuously measured on the surface
since 1957 at monoa in Hawaii and we
know that CO2 is pretty well mixed in
the atmosphere at large so this
measurement is a pretty solid
representation of the global average
concentration of CO2 but CO2 does vary
slightly in concentration by location
and we can measure how using satellites
remember that the key thing about CO2 is
that it absorbs long wavelengths of
light that's how it traps heat in the
atmosphere and prevents it escaping into
space well with the right instrument a
satellite can look down through a column
of air and see how those long wavel
lengths of light get progressively
dimmer the higher and higher you go as
it's absorbed by CO2 and from that it
can infer how much CO2 is present in
total in that column of air specifically
Isa had the envisat mission which used a
scanning Imaging absorption spectrometer
for atmospheric chartography
which could observe the total amount of
CO2 in a given column of air and Issa
isn't alone in this by my counts there
are 10 satellites in orbit right now
measuring CO2 levels and that's going to
increase next year with issa's CO2 m
mission they made a very fancy video
about it okay so the agency's got eyes
on the roof but how does that yes by the
way I bought this hat for this video I'm
going to get value for money but how
does that help us find out who's
responsible for the carbon in the
atmosphere well remember those
atmospheric models that we can run into
the future to determine what the
atmosphere what the weather will look
like in the future well if you put high
resolution CO2 data into those models
then instead of running them forwards in
time to create a forecast you run them
backwards in time to create a hindcast
you can trace where changes in CO2
concentrations originally came from
where the CO2 originally entered the
lowest part of the atmosphere that's
what Dr alel meant when he talked about
inverting the atmospheric model and it's
how we're able to get incredible
Graphics like this from NASA which have
combined observations with the Godard
Earth observing System model to identify
the source of carbon either
anthropogenic or natural and then
tracing those additions to the
atmosphere and letting them build up
over the course of a year you can
accurately estimate if carbon has come
from a natural natural source or Not by
using a dynamic Global vegetation model
by this point we have a very good idea
of how much carbon land with a given
coverage of vegetation and a given
temperature among other factors will
Emit and that's again thanks to
satellite observations as you can
clearly see just like I asked you to
imagine at the start of the video carbon
is building up in the atmosphere and for
various reasons including inverting
atmospheric models but also isotope
analysis we can be very sure most of it
is anthropogenic but unlike the world I
asked you to imagine countries are
owning up to how much CO2 they're
emitting they publish statistics every
year wait this whole bit was for nothing
well it was a way to keep people engaged
with the video the game was rigged from
the beginning but even though countries
report their emissions this satellite
technique is still really important
because it allows us to check if those
Count's emissions reports are actually
accurate in the context of the unfc
Paris agreement countries have to report
the greenhouse gas inventory their
emission and the uh Source every year
and they also have to report the
anthropogenic emission reduction goals
every five years in the context of the
NDC the nationally determined
contribution finally they have all
agreed upon a global stock stake every
five years to assess the collective
progress towards achieving uh the goal
of the Paris agreement and in form of
further measure to be taken if uh needed
in each country National emission
inventory agencies are in charge of
reporting the budget to the unfc and
they are using the bottom up uh approach
they are combining activity statistics
spreadsheets with uh emission uh factors
for example in the USA this emissions
accounting is done by the Environmental
Protection Agency while here in the UK
it's done by the national atmospheric
emissions inventory these agencies
request relevant data from various
governmental and non-governmental
agencies to give an example transport
emissions data here in the UK is
informed by the department for transport
who send an estimate of how many
vehicles are active on the road a
consultancy firm then comes in collects
all of that data fills in the blanks
with some statistics and then publishes
an emissions inventory on the national
atmospheric emissions inventory website
you can look at how British emissions
have changed over the years by sector in
an impressive level of detail you can
even break down the time series of
emissions by sector in a specific County
so here's what it looks like where I
live and it might be the dullest website
I've ever seen in my life I don't know
why because I should find this stuff
interesting but for some reason if
gymnastics was like boredom this website
is like my personal Simone bi anyway
it's one thing for a country to estimate
what its emissions are effectively using
statistics and very educated guesswork
but it's another thing for those numbers
to be accurate and this is where the
satellite hindcast technique is really
valuable a country will say what they
think their emissions are their best
guess and then Issa can run their
atmospheric models in Reverse to find
their estimate of that country's
emissions if the numbers are very
different then something about how that
country is estimating their emissions
isn't quite right to be clear though Isa
isn't looking over country shoulders
it's not checking their working or even
accusing them if their emissions
inventory isn't accurate what they're
providing is a validation tool to help
those countries because it's in a
country's National interest to be
transparent and accurate in this kind of
reporting not being accurate just
damages your trustworthiness we wouldn't
want a country to say one thing about
the environment and then take a bunch of
actions which say something completely
difference that would make them look
untrustworthy so the idea is not to uh
replace the inventory made by uh country
but rather to help them and we can see
that for example not maybe at for small
country but for a group of country
Europe uh North America and we can what
we can assess is uh the trend countries
have to report the anthropogenic
emission reduction goals so every 5
years we can see if it's going in the
right uh Direction uh or not we still
have in the atmospheric convetion a
large uh large uncertainties so instead
of looking at the actual uh number we
can look at the at the tendency and in
that case satellite Earth observation
are very powerful uh tool for policy
implement ation monitoring if a country
say that they will reduce their emission
by this amount at this time we need to
be able to to monitor that from uh from
space but again to assist not to finger
point or or anything like uh like that
the first Global stock take was last
year 2023 when for the first time
countries assessed how their actual
emissions reductions compared to their
emission reduction targets and without
the space-based data sets of Isa and
other bodies those countries will be far
less informed in setting the next lot of
emission reductions targets over the
coming year getting us iteratively
closer to Net Zero so much of the work
of Net Zero is unflashy quiet behind the
scenes calmly objectively pulling
together data sets of carbon emissions
for a country reviewing methodologies
tweaking how emissions estimates are
calculated it may not generate headlines
or a Netflix adaptation anytime soon but
this kind of work done by ESO and others
is the nuts and bolts of science the
foundation stones of how we get out of
this mess because you can't fix a
problem if you don't know how big it is
in the first place there are many ways
that we can establish what a country's
emissions are from the top down from
space or from the bottom up from
emissions inventory and that's a good
thing it's verification hopefully now
you understand a bit more about how we
get to these numbers and crucially how
we improve how we calculate them going
forward
but what I don't understand now is how
those scientist types got so smart and
learned so much math and computer
science or where this accent came from I
can't answer one of those questions but
I can answer the other with
brilliant.org brilliant is the best way
to learn about New Concepts in maths
science and computer science their
website and app provide a low press
Hands-On learning environment in which
you're encouraged to engage with
material that you've literally just met
and play around with it make mistakes
learn their interactive exercises and
beautifully Illustrated courses cover
topics that are super relevant to many
competitive careers including data
science engineering neural networks and
statistics in fact if you enjoyed this
video you'll love their courses on
statistics and if you're learning the
subject in school brilliant is a perfect
supplementary tool you can use at your
own pace to help you understand the
subject from a different angle I've said
time and time again that brilliant is
exactly the resource that I needed
whilst I was in school if I was in
education right now and I had the option
to use Brint I'd absolutely take it it's
a fantastic way to shore up your
understanding of the fundamentals and
support what you're doing in the
classroom from a totally different angle
they're such an easy sponsor to work
with because I genuinely think that the
resource they have created is fantastic
well brilliant to try everything
brilliant has to offer for free for a
full 30 days check out brilliant.org
Simon Clark or click the link in the
subcription and the first 200 of you to
do so will get 20% off a brilliant
annual premium subscription that link
again was brilliant.org Simon Clark with
thanks to brilliant for their continued
support of this channel thank you so
much for watching the video this was a
voyage of Discovery for me which
hopefully came across and uh I enjoyed
it I hope you did too if you enjoyed the
video then you should also probably
thank these lovely people these are my
executive producers on
and then you get early access to videos
you get exclusive behind the scenes
content including a monthly Vlog and you
get to vote on a video topic a month
plus you know you can get your name up
in lights or pixels if you did enjoy the
video please do the YouTube pleasantries
pop it a like comment share it with
people who think may enjoy it and if
you'd like some recommendations for what
to watch next here's two I prepared
earlier that just leades me to say thank
you again for watching and I'll see you
in the next one